you're watching film courage yeah
hello there Karen Borden with film
courage the radio show we're here with
the wonderful Bonnie Gillespie casting
director producer and writer the body
you're very inclusive of actors in the
community you're active on Twitter and
Facebook why are you so generous with
your time in helping these individuals
cultivate their careers a couple reasons
one its it's what I would have wanted
when I was an actor I we all look for
mentors I remember calling around i had
read advice in a book called how to make
it in hollywood and calling around one
of the things that suggested to do is
call and ask someone to mentor you and i
remember a lot of people i don't have
time i don't you know it can't help a
newbie actor through and I and I
remember feeling like wow that it
shouldn't be that way there's no
apprentice program there's no how if we
want professionals in the industry we
need to as professionals reach back and
give them some tips that will help them
become more professional and
professional at any level not just
because they're being paid but also
because as a member of this industry I
want people to be the best that they can
be so if I have information that would
help somebody do a better job when they
audition for me that makes me look good
you know I look brilliant to the
director who hired me if I bring in
people who are more business savvy who
are better prepared who have done their
research and who have learned how to do
all of those things through any tips
that I've been able to provide so to me
it's just a logical give back to the
industry that I'm so passionately
pleased to be a part of
you